hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch
from geek critique I love these kind of
videos Marvel Cinematic Universe
chronological timeline complete Canon
edition as pin comment says this took
him over 200 plus hours to complete well
this will take us over 1 plus hours
maybe 2 to assemble video seriously guys
go check out D critique were subscribed
to this humans Channel this is a topper
work sure Peter crystal man named
Mikhail Linden let's get into this
welcome to this video comprises the
entire live-action Marvel Cinematic
Universe including all shows and gets
into spoiler territory yep if you'd like
to watch the glimpse in the timeline the
only Edition with no spoilers I
recommend it's not the request beautiful
well some films I'm sure was overlap
this timeline will generalize titles
given dates to determine whether or not
it takes place before or after other
titles in the list
giving primary weight to a titles 3rd
act or climax this means you won't be
breaking up the films or shows if they
bounce around between different years
also please note most of the mid and
post credits scenes take place during
different time periods then the film's
they're a tackle that better be in order
have been canceled and they'll remain on
this timeline until officially deemed
let's begin Captain America the First
Avenger sets the backdrop to earth-616
and the Marvel Cinematic Universe as the
first film to introduce superheroes to
the world at least in the modern Network
and there's a new age for mankind
beginning at the height of America's
involvement in World War two the First
Avenger shows the birth of a super hero
one whose moral compass and character
are just as impressive as his enhanced
superhuman abilities taking place
between 1942 and 1945 as well as a short
stint in 2011 this is I think his
physical abilities are more impressive
than his moral compass than the agent
Carter show yep the second title should
definitely be agent Carter season long
yet which follows the love interest of
Steve Rogers in Peggy Carter this takes
place in fall 1946 a year after the end
of the First Avenger
agent Carter season James D'Arcy the
Marvel one-shot agent Carter has been
reckoned to occur after the events from
the first two seasons and sees the start
of what is to become the shield suite
the next film Captain Marvel is one of
the more recent films in the series
though it's chronological placement is
one of the earliest on the timeline my
favorite songs guys John come watch the
video I don't know that along the way
she befriends a young Nick Fury and
discovers the incredible extent of her
power bender
we don't have to do that we push forward
into 2008 with the film that started it
all
Iron Man Tony Stark billionaire weapons
dealer for the US government and CEO of
Stark Industries has a change of heart
after being kidnapped by terrorists
using his own weapons against him upon
discovering shrapnel embedded in his
chest and inching closer to his heart he
finds a new way to power not only hey
guys remember the first time you watch
that movie you ever being in bit feeders
remember us being on the reels channel
what I hope the retconning Iron Man to
occur later than 2008 as this film would
suggest is necessary we've kept it where
it is due to later retcons in the series
and have subsequently moved Iron Man 2
as occurring in 2011 while we won't get
into too much detail as to why this is
necessary here please note that iron
meant to the Incredible Hulk and four
runs semi concurrently if you want more
information we compiled an incredibly
in-depth look at each film in the
timeline in this 24 video series known
as when does the MCU take place it
explains everything
link it in the description down below
everybody now let's get back to the
house West can't wait till they get to
Spider Man home perhaps the most retcons
film in the MCU having replacement
delete after in the role of the Hulk as
well as completely ignoring its own
timeline retroactively the time
abomination altogether yes five years
after Bruce Banner subjects himself to
gamma radiation and develops his alter
ego the Hulk because of its involvement
with Fury's big week a week long period
which also encompasses Iron Man two and
four that those been moved up to the
main that's such a great fight it's such
a great fighter
Marvel one-shots funny thing happened on
the way to Thor's hammer I love this one
for reintroduces the Asgardian - the
Midgard a modern era having been away
long enough for the I should bring the
wide shots back yeah after being
stripped of his titles in rank or less
proved to himself and his king but he is
again worthy to possess the powers once
misto to him and enhanced by his hammer
Mjolnir the burden of the throne is
falling to me now his adopted brother
Loki
here's his stores weakened state to take
control of Asgard Thor occurs in 2011
beginning shortly after iron 19 in the
Incredible Hulk in the Marvel one-shot
the consultants Coulson and Jasper
Sitwell conspired to keep Emma belongs
to his abomination out of the Avengers
initiative this actually occurs before
the mid-credits scene in The Incredible
Hulk for the midterm that scene in the
ultimate really thank you there was an
idea to bring together a group of
remarkable people to see if they could
become something that make a [ __ ] ton of
money and change the industry set almost
one year after Fury's big week the
Avengers team up to stop a global threat
of invasion in 2012 crafted by foolish
brother and some big boys the cone would
not only go on to transform and be
referenced by future MCU films but
became hugely influential and how
Hollywood has approached franchises in
the years since we later find that
Thanos was behind the invasion
if you're enjoying this video that
didn't realize took months of our time
to create let us know by doing some
combination of these four actions I'll
do it all in the Marvel one-shot item 47
we find that - Tommy weaponry is being
found and utilized this was great yeah
this is great
neither have seen this Iron Man 3 sees
individuals from Tony's past coming back
to haunt him as Aldrich Killian and I
introduced the world to the extremis
project I'm not sure if you can tell at
this moment the body is trying to decide
whether to accept extremist or just give
up we're also introduced to someone
claiming to be the Mandarin but we won't
do the tremendous updates for Shang sure
after the events of Thor the dark world
what is generally believed to occur
before the dark it's confusing I break
it down in this video right there
ultimately there must have career prior
to this date on this newspaper during
Christmas 2012 in the Marvel one-shot
all they are the Kings we meet with
Trevor Slattery to determine if he truly
knows anything more about the man were
away forever quickly a few months after
our memory now we begin the introduction
of agents of shield as we dive into seas
at all because it just shows long 22
episode format and the apparent time
breaks within each season we can place
most of the show with some certainty
especially in its earlier seasons hey
there are two ways we can do this Oh
anyway no the first seven episodes
introduce us to the shield team for the
dark world naturally comes next but I
saw you on TV you were you ain't New
York every five thousand years a murder
the Nazarene realms opens a portal
between worlds and Malekith uses it to
unleash the power of the ether to
transform the universe back into eternal
darkness the convergence occurs on
November 17 2013 is this the worst film
the timeline I personally enjoy it then
what is the worst film agents of shield
season 1 arrives next with revenge in
episode 8 picking up after the dark
world and events in episode 16 leading
into the Winter Soldier with Captain
America the Winter Soldier we find
ourselves in the summer of 2014
result agency oh good Joey 21st century
Steve Rogers along with natasha romanoff
find themselves on the run from a broke
cell that's taken over shield in Hydra
and a brand new thought as we discovered
Bucky has become the Winter Soldier
season 1 episode 17 through 20 to deal
directly with the massive curveball of
Hydra infiltrating the shield whoa he's
in the show whoa that's what happens
it's not really John's done guardians of
the galaxy takes place 26 years after
Peter quill a young boy from Missouri is
abducted in 1988 John didn't explain to
you guys why he's doing that he is
covering it up patreon is only on season
1 we can only assume that guardians of
the galaxy occurs sometime during the
summer of 2014 shortly after the Winter
Soldier this could take place at any
time arms or galaxies away mysterious
entity introduces himself to Peter as
ego his father who helps unlock the true
potential I go not all is as it seems
being half celestial has its drawbacks
[Music]
that's why this film likely occurs mid
to late fall 2014 daredevil season yes
and fighting crime by night
Wilson Fisk is perhaps the best villain
but not so received with any of the
Marvel TV shows and is up there with the
top mc2 villains in general
oh we're with Jessica Jones season 1 we
close out 2014 with Jessica going up
against her prior abuser kilgrave and
one of the MCS most chilling chapters
you API I'm just trying to make a living
you know who's cost money usually we're
also introduced to looky-looky cloak and
dagger season 1 while striving in 2018
actually takes place eight years after
2007 which makes it early does it really
I'm Ronen Tandy become intertwined with
powers of life in darkness and was bad
together to take down the evil corporate
entity rocks on this day and age you
need to keep our choices never saw any
clothes better Starks and Rams watching
us on patreon so I'm gonna stop watching
now every time periods of time it
doesn't
that said episode 19 ties directly into
Avengers age of wha that's what happens
and Bruce unintentionally alisha
dangerous artificially intelligent
lifeform into the world Ultron is intent
on machines this event takes place in
this summer of 2015 as becomes evident
by other titles in the series the final
three episodes 20 through 22 follow
along sokovia
we have the first season of whi H news
from a youtube series of 5 episodes that
chronicles the media coverage posted Co
what I've never heard of this yeah she's
an Ironman wanted to this was released
on YouTube originally what has since
been removed we want right here and
we've left it unmonitored because wait
what when they take it down which takes
place how are they letting you keep
after a few months of trying to make a
living and willing to pay child support
fewer words
to his old ways of burglary only to find
a dusty old suit that happens to be able
to make him shrink down to the size of a
net and man 3 was just announced oh so
excited billion dollars
the film's climax occurs on October 9th
2015
Simmons is trapped in monolith world in
the first half of agents of shield
season 3 episodes 1 through 10 shortly
after it's done daredevil season 2 is
next all the Avengers appear an agency
does that mean you're reauthorizing the
public has a blade
Bridget O'Reilly returns to
cloak-and-dagger season 2 alongside
mayhem her double game if all of shortly
after Luke Cage season 1 and actually
discusses some of the events outlined at
the end of Luke ages first season oh
really - 2016 Luke Cage though please
bear in mind is that the recent news
that Coke and dagger and the runaways
team are teaming up in runaways the
season 3 might mean that they are
pushing the timeline for the entire flow
over dagger series up two years but
that's not been determined yet
Oh keyboardist now that's complicated
season 1 telelink us 15 years chose to
balance whether or not his duties to his
family's legacy are more important than
who he is as the iron fist
defender season 1 picks up just a short
month or so after iron fist and follows
the entire Netflix Marvel cast except
the Punisher as they collectively take
down the hand organization from
destroying New York City ya know wh
there were two seasons
again we'll make all parties newsfront
series in the description
you like my MCU time lecture well you
can grab yours now in our merch store
link just below this video and you'll
help support the production of more
content just like this you know because
it's a two hundred hours to get together
he deserves to play something different
every three to five movies per second
notice a it does deserve to protect
citizens across sovereign borders due to
damage they may or may not have been
responsible for this is I don't care
[Music]
the America's civil wars climax occurs
within the first week of April 2016 and
sees the Avengers to slip out in the
middle please note though many films of
Kurt in 2016 there is a fair amount of
laughing again for much more detail
please see our when does the MCU
timeline take place series Black Panther
picks up a week after King to Shaka is
killed in a terrorist attack that
occurred during civil wars time this
trip don't follow this is one we
undergoes the coronation ritual upon
arriving back at this country at Locanda
an African utopia hidden away from the
rest of the world telling Godfather's
challenged for the throne by Erik could
kill longer this ultimate goal is to
help aid those of African descent by
arming them with the common technologies
so they can overthrow their governments
this Howell weapons will not be used to
wage war on the world a film occurs as
early as the second week of April and
spans only a few days let's close out
agents of shield season 3 episodes 22 22
all the Netflix characters appear film
which introduces one of Marvel's most
popular heroes and one of the MCS most
personable villains to Dayton the
butchery goes but I'm waiting for
justify this
almost every day time and reference to
susan is contradicted by other films in
the MCU or my homecoming itself this
video right here explains how because
people care so much about that I love
the HBM song they chose Doctor Strange
comes next on our timeline though like
we mentioned earlier there's some
overlap with other films in 2016 in fact
Doctor Strange begins before even civil
war revolving around Stephen strange
getting into an accident
the climax occurs at the tail end of
2016 and the mid-and post-credits scenes
occur in the 2017 one Stephen apparently
feels proficient enough to protect the
eye of agamotto from his sanctuary in
New York City the beginning screenshot
slingshot web series takes place after
episode 8 of agents of shield season 4 I
heard mix was calling you in you're
sounding the sokovia accords
John Mikey got his own plot line on the
show let me push my earbuds in closer I
don't think he even watched an
underrated season I love this season
poor miss Dina so many shows she doesn't
get it
anything well the first handful of
episodes in agents of shield season 5
her over
our f1 future will adhere to the
characters relative fine lines which
whoa when did you first come here
minimum no Ragnarok sees the return of
Thor's deranged older sister hello and
I'm freezing off against her in the
Bifrost it's transported to the alien
world of Sekar he's so beautiful again
Tiki Watts despite what the mid-credits
scene would have you believe fool
Ragnarok does not take place directly
before it anymore
there is about a five to seven month
yeah between the film's main events
there's about a ten-minute gap for
season two arrives next in or around
November 27 so since Danny lose his
grasp on this mantle and is a marked
improvement in some ways to the first
season over a lot of ways the season
grew me a lot
what a great fight that's a great fight
2017 shortly after those two white guys
going fishing Manolis runaways Oh
let's take place over the winter holiday
seasons cool the season two the cast
doing what they have to do damage there
they're getting just a day after the end
of the first season and is the last
a man in the loft however occurs
mid-april 2018 the film takes place a
little over two years after civil war
and this is notable it's not things just
about to end his probation period for
events he hated in such film he and hope
become entangled in the quantum ice as
Hank Pym attempts to bring Janet back
from comes after this one entangling
now for the Black Widow to infinity and
we've even mentioned that on occasion
here but aside from the mid-credits
scene where we see the effects of this
spot there's no evidence that that is
the case between the climax and the
credits scene is at least a week-long
resolution very the final four episodes
agents of shield season five episodes 19
to 22 lead into the events of infinity
references to Panos The Avengers and
even the aliens of New York really I
don't think they're really there
Avengers infinity war occurs over three
days with the climactic snappy after
April 19th 2018 the latest day would
probably need a pro today he oversees
the math tiny atoms that have to read
half the universe of life by collecting
all six Infinity stones are you so cool
[Music]
agents of shield season six we'll just
have to go here until they explain it is
supposed to be here after the snap but
there's no reference to it in the
straightest and nobody appears effect
this may be the last iteration of this
timeline unless something further is
clarified Avengers in game to infinity
I've seen this
but there will be as easy as it sounds
endgame bounces around on the timeline
primary time period is over five years
after I marry me and the audience thing
he's been 16 for over 18 months what if
his birthday is August 10th he was
booked back in October he wouldn't count
that year as he's only ever experienced
16 August 10th so
wowee-wow-wow they make videos like this
possible even if it's just a dollar a
month thank you guys
if you'd like to join our patreon we'll
link it in the description below this
video and please do some combination of
these four actions if you choose to
subscribe to our channel about this
video in general please click here and
watch this especially crafted playlist
called when does the MCU take place
which is an in-depth look at each film
in the time thank you
it's video sucked man yeah what gives
all wrong and they time better videos
that's great honestly I'm just surprised
by where agents of shield takes place by
the time you get that 6 season oh yeah I
want to tell me about it like all about
it yeah tell me what I missed in the
video fan Oh shows up alright wide
punches Coulson in the face oh I love
that character of Coulson the agent
takes a dump on all of them oh that's
gross and an ant man shows up he goes up
Thanos his butt finally is that where we
finally got the thing done on agents of
shield prime time a bow I was daredevil
season 3 okay human X there you go yeah
I'm a bad Marvel fan I'm a fake nerd you
guys you really are I am this video made
me hope Topher Grace can take on another
demanding role so that he can make some
kind of super cut he talks about a lot
during these about how this movie takes
place over different parts of the
timeline so some of it would take place
here so what I want is a kite where
somebody puts all the footage in
sequential
very long I think we'd have to mix in
the end game footage to you when they're
going back in time and that in that big
act that we find out kind of and now I
mess with the continuity because
actually now that doesn't make sense
they're in an alternate timeline so no
there's no point in doing that yeah I
changed my mind
I check for my completely but in all
seriousness with agents of shield what
impressed me about this I won't spoil
okay okay well like the Netflix shows
and the cloak and dagger and runaways
while there's like nods and and like
some slight references to the events in
the movies agents of shield I'm spoiling
anything for one that was not run at all
by Kevin Feige Jeph Loeb who is known to
not have had a great relationship with
Kevin Feige they didn't really see eye
to eye on a lot of creative choices
there's a lot of creative differences
and a lot of the things that happen with
agents of shield I remember hearing
about this from Winter Soldier it came
out of like a bomb just kind of got
dropped on them of the events that
happened in Winter Soldier or they
dismantle shield and then they have to
readjust to the movie timeline and then
it seems like they've had to do that for
a lot of this series I would not be an
old yes I actually just got to the point
in the show streaming along on patreon
you get that big Hydra bomb drop so I've
arrived at the first major twist of the
show right see cuz like what season came
out after infinity war with the Netflix
shows there was no acknowledgement of
like the snap or anything like that
they completely didn't care they're just
doing their own thing and then while
watching all these things about agents
of shield the way he divided it up which
does take a lot of calculation a lot of
work of what you did here specially with
the episodes broken down exactly you
didn't just go season one takes place
here season two you'd have to go like
episodes before through late in season
three take place in between Ragnarok or
something you know which I thought was
really impressive and I appreciate the
time and work that you put into this
yeah I'm gonna miss those Netflix shows
so much and I gotta say this Jessica
Jones with Trish Walker is the worst
character to have ever existed on
television I do not dislike the actress
I just think the writers hater or the
producers or something the show clearly
does not I think
hate her so much I don't think I've ever
hated a character on TV as much as I've
hated her I think the reason why I hate
her so much because she's not supposed
to be unlikable he's no like a villain I
mean she becomes that you're not gonna
become a villain
well yeah but but that's like so late
into the final parts of season three
then you're like okay I guess they're
trying to justify the amount of
annoyance you've sat with this character
she's supposed to be a protagonist that
you care about there was so much of that
series and with season two especially
season two ends and then when you go to
see things like oh my gosh I don't know
why there's so much emphasis on her and
I'm bummed that that was the last
Netflix installment we got to close it
outlet and I'm also bun that it was the
last one I wonder what's gonna happen in
the future of those with this whole
rumor about FX and stuff like that it's
just nice that they got in there at all
you know and I also too I mean I
we've talked precious little on our
whole organization about Runaways and
cloak-and-dagger oddly enough this
highlighted those things that I'm less
familiar with the crossover is there
because I remember seeing at least part
of Runaways season 1 and I had no idea
that cloak and dagger was gonna cross
over that mark and dagger was canceled I
thought it was too but maybe they're
gonna save it by putting them into the
Runaways or something like that now I've
never heard of this YouTube show with
Vic you talking about yeah the news
front that that is brand spanking new to
me man yeah I wish I caught that because
that sounds pretty sweetly now you can
on this very channel until the powers
that be come in and vaporize you for
uploading their content to be pretty I
am I'm really surprised by how much
would I mean do you watch all these
shows do you did you watch all of these
cuz that's a lot of hours to keep up
with or did you have a team you know
saying we in the team but when there
were the credits were there it was all
him this is really impressive I'm like
looking at this final image of all the
movies yeah overwhelmed by how yeah
especially with all that repetition of
like the difference yeah cuz like the
shows make it that much more kind of
overwhelming and my point to that with
being like a Marvel fan is you got all
these Marvel shows that have either just
been dropped and especially amongst a
Netflix round like I don't watch agents
of shield and I didn't see any of agent
Carter but I
there's a lot of fans for those you know
I cloak-and-dagger and Runaways I'm not
sure what's happening with that a lot of
them don't get the full-on resolution
and sucks when things are dropped or not
acknowledge any more like Incredible
Hulk well I think is not a great MCU
film I think because they replaced their
lead actor they've just tried dropping
so much that movie completely yeah it's
like you got William Hurt who you're
acknowledging they make references to it
in other films but I still think that
there's plenty of great things I
wouldn't mind seeing abomination come
back III think that final fight is one
of the best fights in the MCU I love
that final fight they make reference to
him on agents of shield he's technically
still out there canonically sure I mean
I kind of doubt we'd see him again in
the near future but I think that would
be a cool asset to have in the back
pocket especially now you see if the
Mandarin come back you know after so
long being away maybe they're gonna do
that kind of thing were they gonna put
Blonsky away for a long time and then
bring him back when maybe we start doing
solo Hulk's again because that's the
other thing I've been wondering about is
are we ever gonna see another solo Hulk
and I know there are rights issues to
that at some point they've gotta we've
worked out spider-man to a degree you
know I really know if there's much of a
demand for a solo Hulk movie as there
was for spider-man though you know
there's two things I want to bring up
first off with the Mandarin Iron Man 3
and the Marvel one-shot all hail the
king came right after look at this it
was pretty early on yeah you know is
right after the first Avengers movie and
then for the longest time we've been
wanting a course correction on Mandarin
I'm curious if it is the right time to
do with Shane Chi and the ten rings I
was at WonderCon movie fights and my
question that I was asked on the screen
junkies panel which MCU villain deserves
another shot and I was saying they got
to redo the manner we were promised that
we still haven't gotten in ten rings was
established in Iron Man one that hasn't
been a rapper out with it's I find it
fascinating how it seemed like if
they're gonna conclude that or wrap it
up at least with a completely different
character
Shane Shane Chi it's just funny after so
many years and so many movies and shows
that we're finally getting that wrapper
happen the other thing they also linked
to movie fights because this was an easy
answer for me to speed round question
because it's how they have always
thought with the defenders the question
I was asked was which cancel TV show
deserves a movie follow up and I was
like I think it should be the defense
I think that would be such a cool way to
conclude like the defenders show wasn't
that good it definitely didn't live up
to the hype and the expectations of it
all I still think it would be pretty
amazing if we were able to close out
this Netflix chapter which I think had
more of an impact I mean it's still this
one show but in terms of like
establishing a small universe within the
universe on a different program that
feels convincingly connected defenders
would be a really cool like one movie
just to close it off like they're El
Camino or whatever to wrap it all up or
what they just did with Deadwood on HBO
something like that yeah actually I mean
yeah cuz I didn't see the defenders
series but age of fanservice I feel like
that is arguably to me the most
qualitative version of fanservice I mean
I can do without a million Easter eggs
if it means whoa what we need Easter I
need them that's what makes these movies
what they are truly it's not the plot
what new rockstars gonna do if it's not
a billion Easter eggs all right I know I
know they're whole ecosystems that
thrive off these week it's a second to
Easter eggs in terms of fanservice I
think there's something like that yeah
where there are characters that people
love I don't know what the
decision-making has been especially with
these Netflix series but it seems like
the people who care are numerous and
yeah would love some kind of conclusive
defenders thing and I feel like that's
the kind of thing that Walt may be
modest would turn some kind of numbers
profit however they measure those
metrics and I feel like it would be nice
in a universe that has so many threads
and ways to leave loose ends it's like
we're very committed now in culture to
having this MCU thing be what it is yeah
and the defenders especially I mean like
cloak-and-dagger The Runaways you have
these tears where those seem like this
sort of smaller end so it would be
harder to make an argument to like
conclude those if one is canceled on
ceremoniously or something but yeah the
defenders seems like it would be really
nice for everybody who invested and a
way to get people to maybe not be so
heartbroken moving forward that there
gonna be a way if you could give them a
fitting send-off versus just like the
show's ended you know they also should
bring back the one shots that would be
read it seemed to be like a especially
look at this timeline
was like a pretty consistent thing that
they were doing for a while and then it
kind of got dropped and I really enjoyed
the one shot I thought they were all
pretty I can't think of one that I was
like yeah I thought they're all pretty
awesome yeah they're a nice chance to
add some extra context and add like a
cool splash of filmmaking now I think
they ought to start doing movies that
just take place in random moments just
to mess up this timeline you know like
in between agents of shield season 3
episodes 11 through 19 in the middle of
it you know sandwich by Luke Cage season
1 yeah but it's also taking place during
parts of Doctor Strange because of you
know the difference yes a multiverse
time loops and strike that I think you
just got to start messing this old this
whole thing up just an MCU movie that's
an anthology of single scenes that are
all in different time places universes
etc now man Wow then when we start doing
the Disney Plus shows how avant-garde I
don't know who has seen all of these
sound off as someone has there are
people who definitely add I'm not one of
them because there's a few things for
him like I haven't seen that let us know
how bad spider-man homecoming jar's your
yes list here well thank you geek
critique for putting this together you
did an awesome awesome job I love this
and now I know how I have to watch the
MCU movies yeah I've been doing the
wrong full-time guys you can subscribe
to geek critique link in the description
box link in the pin comment as well you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can click that notification bell to get
notified whenever we got a youtube video
what Mikael thank you so much for
requesting this dude Mikael did say that
if there's a trailer for no time to die
which is the Bond movie that he would
like that to be his type of war to
request I believe that trailer will not
be coming for another month I just want
to say I'm lying no time to die trailer
comes out in a couple of days I just
didn't want to dedicate that video to
use sucker only was you're a bad Bond
fandom whatever you misogynistic
alcoholic Swedish jerk yeah why do you
worship bond he's a horrible
person you should stop trying to be like
it maybe you could find true love if you
didn't worship that character yeah you
ever think about that Mikael you ever
think about that but thank you so much
for being a part of our patreon page see
there's a point where you're like all we
talk about is you being Swedish and
James Bond and you told me a couple of
facts about yourself and then we quickly
moved on past that and talked more about
James but next shout-out is just going
to be a chronological order of all your
shout